when you're evaluating finding the value
of these these objects here each log
equation like the ones that are written
here marries up to an exponential
equation an equation with something
raised to a power so all the same
numbers just slightly rearranged so as
an example
can someone help me out the first one is
the easiest one what equation could we
write that uses 3 9 and 2 but without
logs you argue 3 squared equals 9
perfect it should always have in your
mind this equation when you look at this
what about this one
someone else who wants to help us out I
have a big 5 okay no quadrant board you
meet yet ok so cordial usually needs
multiply by 4 but if you raise to the
power of 4 and that's what gives you 625
these last two are a bit sneaky up
because they're not just regular old
whole number powers opposite on powers
what's this sec this looks like a last
one how do you get a fraction what power
is that the negative fractions sorry
negative powers will give you fractions
so 6 to the negative 1 that's 1 over 6
now the last one is sneaky a lot of
people will see that and I'll say the
answer is 2 why do you think someone
might look at that and think the answer
is 2 4 divided by 2 is 2 or thinking
about powers 2 squared squared is 4 but
do you see it's in the wrong direction
to the wrong direction what you really
want what's the equation that goes with
this without logs is 4 to the power of
1/2 that's the square root of 4 that's
equal to 2 ok so again I want to
highlight to you and I'd love if you've
written down these equations you should
have done these equations the bases are
the things which are the slave so this
base of 3 becomes this base of 3 this
base of 5 this base of 6 this space of 4
ok and then the other guys are the ones
that shuffle around ok well done you can
rule that off and then the heading I'd
like you to make is
logarithm logarithm mores okay now I
want you to look at this one in here for
a second log base 5 of 6 to 25 equals 4
I want to explore some logs that are
related to this one okay because all we
do it is thinking about an exponential
equation from a different perspective
that's all it is you're interested in
what's the power instead of if you know
what the power is how big does the thing
and done okay so along with this I want
you to help me consider two related
equations let's think about or two
related logs this guy and this guy can
we think about these log base 5 of 5 if
you're growing at a rate of 5 how long
does it take you to get to 5 what power
do I need to raise - it's just one isn't
it what about 125 how many times do I
have to multiply by 5 to get 225 3 times
right now I want you to look at these
two in relation to question 2 and we're
going to develop a law out of this you
guys remember we were thinking about
indices and stuff like that laws are
just shortcuts that allow you do stuff
quicker without going through all of the
hand calculations okay firstly have a
look at this if I hadn't written fines
if I'd written say log base 4 or 4 or
log base a hundred of 100 on log base PI
of Pi
how would that change the answer it it
won't change the matter what numbers
you're putting if they're the same
number you always get one because that's
the power you raised you to get the same
number so I can generalize this I could
write a law that takes this and says
well for any number for any number like
let's just call it a I use algebra when
I don't know what numbers are dealing
with so this is a way of saying any W
like log base a
of a is always every time going to be
one no matter what a is okay so that's a
law right it's not so much that you need
to memorize this because someone said
it's important but it's just quicker to
do that than to think every time what
about this one
what about base 3 of 3 or base 8 of 8 or
something like that okay good we're
going to develop another law as we
consider both of these together now and
how they relate to this do you see that
if I add these two equations together I
get this equation
do you notice that if I add these two on
the Left add them on the right I get
this to see that so what I wanted to do
let's just label these equation one and
equation two if I add equation one and
two then I will find this log base 5 of
5 log base 5 of 105 that's 4 but for
Yuri Toby was this right so from that I
gain this okay now have a look the law
is going to emerge out of this right 5
125 625 what's the way that I combine
these two in order to get this what I do
I multiply it don't like 5 times 125
equals 625 yes so how can I turn this
into how can I state this as a law well
I can say log base five oops five log
base 5 of 125 is equal to the base is
going to stay the same
everything that I'm writing an orange
right now is base five that hasn't
changed at all but over here this is the
product of five and 125 so let me just
emphasize that
there's the 5 there's 125 there's the
product ok is it true for any numbers
that we like well I'd think about this
one at the top with my black good here
there is height let's figure that out
one log base 3 of 9 if I add that to log
base 3 of say 27 you already know what
this one is you wrote down that value
it's - what's this one 3 it's just it's
just the next power up right is that
equal to put your question mark E is
that equal to what's nine times 27
that's a big number 243 is that equal to
243 mod based you at 243 does what if
this is the question I gave you what
would you find is the value 3 to the
power of what gives you 2 points and
it's 5 isn't it 2 plus 3 is 5 it is
equal so this seems to be true I can add
logs if you add logs you're going to
multiply together the numbers in those
logs so long as the base into the center
ok so I'm going to write a lawn now ok
I'll go back to Orange the law is that
log base let's say a of a number any
numbers you're like right these could be
anything so I'm going to call these guys
P and Q you've got the same base but you
got any two numbers here you like what
will you do to those numbers how will
you combine them you will multiply them
the base stays the same but you multiply
those two numbers together ok
okay now this is weird this is for here
you add things you add things that turns
into multiplication do you know of any
other kind of area of mathematics where
adding and multiplying you're kind of
related to each other in this way have a
think yeah I mean what do you think you
know that's fine that's ok it's alright
to contemplate this to make is a weird
question to pose ok Isabelle do you ever
thought you just wave your pen room yeah
remember when I said look at these AZ a
a and a you've got the same base that's
really important if I change the bases
this is all a bit different